[Musique]
au final ils ont ils sont 7 milles 7
milles environ en france dit personnes
de petite taille dont la taille varie de
1 m à 1 m 40 10 % seulement parviendront
à s'insérer dans le monde du travail
emmanuel sept ans seul enfant à contre
place d'une famille normale commencent à
prendre conscience des difficultés qui
l'attendent
les parents des manuels tente avec le
peu de moyens dont ils disposent de le
rapprocher de la normalité et ce n'est
ni sans douleur ni sans angoisse
aufeminin que dimanche on vient quand il
a commencé à 24 ans il y avait des
enfants qui lui il faisait des petites
réflexions à l'école bon il a ramené le
mode 1 alors ils demandaient ils
demandaient qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire allonger lisez bien c'est quelqu'un
qui est petit
la victime elle adéquate chinois pour
que tu le dis sans
c'est parce que c'est vrai ma seule
s'est fait que préfet c'est presque vrai
petit à petit dans ses premières fois et
tu te bats avec eux quand même oui mais
qu'est ce qu'ils gagnent là toujours
j'aimerais bien gagner une fois ouais
et je pense que c'est pas possible c'est
une fois il est revenu d'école il dit
c'est vrai que je vais que je serai dans
la cire plus tard dit non il dit
pourquoi tu dis ça mais ils disent et
ils me disent les autres camarades qui
me l'ont dit à l'école moi je dis y'a
pas de raison ils disent des bêtises tu
feras un métier comme les autres il a
pas de raisons dont les problèmes sont
multipliées par deux défaites de sa
petite taille c'est certain mais y'a pas
de raison et j'espère bien qu'il aura
une situation c'est une situation plus
tard pourquoi pas presqu'autant de forme
de nanisme que denain l'une des plus
fréquentes la contrôler asie le tronc
est normal mais les membres son coût
réfléchi et la tête grosse la colonne
vertébrale souvent déformée nécessite
une surveillance constante
allez emmanuel porte jour et nuit depuis
deux ans un corps c'est que parfois il
ne peut plus supporter mais il devra le
garder encore cinq ans
longtemps qu'il est bébé bombail et
reste dans la famille dans son milieu
il ya personne qui regarde c'est quand
il commence à aller à l'école dans la
rue commence à se retourner
là c'est plus gênant que vous faites
j'avais senti coupable lorsque cet
enfant est né
[Applaudissements]
on se sent quand même un peu coupable et
après on finit par dire toute façon
c'est un tout autre
on a toujours des réactions s'est plaint
le lendemain mon copain savez quand bien
vous recherchez sur le lieu de travail
qu'on vous dit il faut du temps le
professeur il ya des anomalies bon c'est
vrai on pensons qu est-ce qui vous a dit
mon professeur il m'a dit bon ben il ya
certaines anomalies il dit et la grosse
tête il ya ses doigts qui sont que son
ego et sera pas très grand alors la
première fois il m'a dit mon beffroi un
mètre cinquante monde sait bien c'est un
mètre cinquante
je fais est reparti en tournée de voir
qu'un jour après savait déjà diminué
puis j'ai retourné le revoir un mois
après alors là aussi ça mais diminuent
si pour les autres enfants la piscine
est un plaisir pour emmanuel ce n'est
pas le cas mais il sait qu'il n'a pas le
choix
[Musique]
ouais bien fait
et c'est avec abnégation que pendant des
heures et des heures
semaine après semaine il répétera
inlassablement les mêmes mouvements est
toujours sous le regard des autres ont
créé un peu la façon dont lui en
grandissant on pourrait peut toujours me
dire pourquoi il est comme ça enfin
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude ça pour nous
c'est sûr temps qui va être jeune ya
patrie pratiquement pas de problème
les problèmes commencent adolescence et
puis après à l'âge adulte avec le
travail
[Musique]
christophe 14 ans autre sorte de nanisme
le nanisme hypophysaires une quantité
insuffisante d'hormones dans l'organisme
aujourd'hui il est peut être possible
d'y remédier mais pour christophe lui
aussi il est parfois difficile
d'affronter les choses de la vie
[Musique]
alors c'est preque trois pommes et noix
[Applaudissements]
ebel fois j'étais en vacances avec eux
avec guy l'eau puis l'a dit complètement
dès qu'un lieu
j'étais petite et petite taille parce
que tes parents ont fait la loi en
défaut ce qu'ils n'ont pas gâché un
amour du maillot jaune empochera vous là
ils l'ont fait alors une petite taille
moi j'essaye d'expliquer ses pinceaux
c'est la nature ses parents
je dois suivre avec nous les piqûres
mais l'hormone profit j'en ai sept par
semaine
bon ça fait se rhabiller tout faire du
tout genre très bas jusqu'au jarosz me
permets tu fais pour mon bien que j'en
fais ça fait quand même moi je les
écoute et les leurs comme beaucoup avant
je conçois j'avais un retard de -26%
maintenant j'ai un retard de -18 kani et
se retrouve à res
et je profite des ex future ligue 1 au
delà du profit puisque quand j'étais
petit jules chez les problèmes j'espère
atteindre d'après ce que m'ont dit les
notre coeur un médecin qu'entraîneur 55e
tu crois
tu es un staff romain barras projet
tandis que l'écossais et pourtant c'est
beau c'est votre porte
[Applaudissements]
je suis embêté par la police l'eau dans
les jambes sur les chats
[Musique]
jean-philippe bergeal 36 ans 95 cm
hypophysaires lui aussi solitaire par
obligation il rêvait de faire de la
politique ou du journalisme et 7 à force
de ténacité qu'il est devenu aujourd'hui
expert comptable
je
il vit encore chez sa mère âgée
elle-même de 72 ans et c'est avec
fatalisme qu'il affronte son avenir bref
c'est être entouré est ce qu'en fait on
retrouve au contraire de ce qu'on a le
plus important la solitude ci ne pas
pouvoir parler personne à qui parler
parce qu'on a besoin de parler
moi j'ai lu la lecture pendant qu'on
peut condamner la lecture c'est quand
même et non comme ça qu'on a un livre
ses cinq compagnons
le premier vous proposer à la limite
vous parlez avec le personnage qu'on me
disait il faut il faut arriver à
quelqu'un bon il faut se faire une
raison
finalement les autres c'est beaucoup
mais je crois qu'en fait qu'ils font le
clézio qui se pensent qu'il faudrait
d'abord que pour qu'ils essayent de se
voir à se regarder en même si les autres
c'est penser d'abord à rue pendant leur
garde et reçoit même je crois que les
autres quand ils critiquent beaucoup
mais s'ils se regarder davantage il se
verrait aussi avec beaucoup de défauts
le vieux proverbe me regarde toi toi
même
là on l'a pas été tant l'oeil dans la
poule du voisin c'est ça pourquoi les
gens ils pensent à regarder que les
autres alors à eux mêmes ils ne
l'avaient pas
on veut pas se permettre un autre époque
des d'avoir des gens différents
parce que l'ap a été passé cela n'a pas
été pleinement et en effet pour vivre à
part entière donc à arrive dans le
circuit il n'ya pas n'est pas de société
idéale
justement
n'est pas il n'y a pas des gens normaux
ne pas de gens normaux il ya des gens
qui sont différents par apprendre et
pourquoi différents en fait rochus et
c'est ça le ski pour voir
richard jusqu'à l'âge de 29 ans richard
goode sq et rester dans le cocon
familial
c'est l'association des gens de petite
taille qu'il en a sorti en lui faisant
prendre conscience qu'il était temps de
voler de ses propres ailes
[Musique]
c'est pas la famille qui m'as tu m'as
malige était sa jetée bombe en belgique
c'est l'extérieur nous observent dans le
dos on ressent tout de suite
ah c'est un regard moqueur un regard pas
de pitié avec un regard de tueur qui
prête à rire est prête à sourire les
gens du cirque et vous les halles animal
unique au monde dans un dans l'île
sp sera autre chose
là on est d'ailleurs il a envie de
cogner et comment votre mère vives ces
regards là elle sentait coupable
tout ce que je peux dire
coupât pour vous pour les autres elle
coupa par rapport à moi pas pour les
autres
ben vous liez est à cette époque la peau
de santé gérés par rapport à mon frère
ça ça dérange
j'avais un directement involontairement
ouais mon frère je devais dérangé par
rapport à la salle afin de société
certaines périodes
je pense que mon frère s'est détaché 2
mois mais a volontairement
involontairement
c'est pas qu'il va racheter
il s'est détaché 2 mois c'est à dire je
n'en veux pas au delà
au contraire
richard travaille au crédit lyonnais
depuis 1969 et dans la vie monotone de
richard qui essaye d'exister de toutes
ses forces
malgré l'indifférence de l'environnement
il y aura désormais à n'y a ni cerpi
n'était avec qui il y a quatre mois
richard a décidé de se marier
ali 36 ans est à condroz place comme lui
elle travaille dans la pharmacie de sa
mère à tourrettes sur loup
[Musique]
annie aurait pu être pharmacienne elle
aussi mais l'université ne lui en a pas
laissé la possibilité est aujourd'hui
aucun pharmaciens d'officine ne veulent
employer à paris nice et te plaît oui et
1 bat rim suspension sokou merci
ohlala hawass
ah non je fais ou terminal à terminal
maillot laborde et les carreleurs france
ah ouais j'ai fait ça pour entrer dans
des calices mots je suis actuellement on
est passé par un concours et j'ai passé
le concours je les réussis
j'étais encore un doigt cette époque là
après le concours on a eu un entretien
avec des joies des psychologues la la la
chose là ça a commencé à déranger parce
que richard et les autres c'était
différent
non c'est chouette mais bon vu dans
chair et en os sur pied ils ont été
gênés savais pas qu'il était jeune et si
c'était moi où j'étais accessible j'ai
j'avais réussi l'examen
la preuve on a présenté ma candidature
dans tous les services du crayonné de la
région parisienne tout en notifiant bien
n'est ce pas que monsieur booth richert
a été un homme
je précise bien là dessus sur son père
va régler dans un service à bachot
recherche qu'est ce que ça va faire on
concevait pas que je puisse paraître aux
yeux du public
moi je suis fait toute ma vie pour être
en service à l'abri du public
je suivais chevaux c'est la blonde alors
à ces trucs c'est bien le dr 10,3
m
merci moi je suis penché ce roulante je
me dépêche de partout et je suis
acceptée par tous avec le souverain donc
on va on aime discuter avec moi j'me
tire pas dans ma coquille contraire au
boulot je pense
richert sortir avec les collègues
samedi soir on y arrivera mais au départ
à une certaine réticence
jean
m
vous auriez pu épouser une personne de
grande taille pour rapport mais je me
suis rangé je me suis retranchée sur une
certaine normalisation est sûre il y
aurait des problèmes et beaucoup plus
qu'avec ali
[Applaudissements]
du coup je pense par la visite médicale
et
je vais voir m
l'école de conduite
voilà qui va qui a trouvé que j'avais
assez
de réflexes pour pouvoir conduire
j'ai représente peut être conduire
pendant une certaine liberté pas et
s'éloigne quand je me sens énervé quand
j'ai besoin d'eux je prends la voiture
j'ai besoin de nous sommes d'une
certaine liberté
piché gens roulent comme ça sans but
j'aime bien
à n'importe quelle heure de la journée
quand je me sens pas bien angoissés car
tout de suite eu par la voiture je sais
que ça me calme
je viens je
je finis
je me considère vraiment content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
anne et allez ça va c'était moche
ben moi je t'appelle d'une cabine
téléphonique là
[Musique]
je suppose que vous êtes contente qu'un
10 marie ah oui le scrutin longtemps
mais je ne pensais pas que ça nagerait
comment elle est votre robe de mariage
là ça va que je suis toujours dit que le
jour où j'aurai une robe de mariée
passera blanc cassé au champagne
il y aura des enfants décortiquer les
tout petits qui sont tout petits
oui ton petit le petit que nous c'est ce
que je voulais et si elle n'était pas
mariée
qu'est ce qui serait arrivé justement je
ne le suis demandé très longtemps je ne
voyais pas dans la famille quelqu'un qui
puisse prendre la charge d'une enfant
voisins vous venez de me dire la charge
d'une enfant comme sa poche mais à son
âge ce n'est plus une enfant dans les
bras de maman j'ai toujours un enfant
mais elle particulièrement je vais tout
devient bus quand vous dites que vous
l'avez tous donné vous pouvez expliquer
je vais donner toute ma vie j'ai renoncé
à refaire ma vie à présent sachant pas
comment n'accepterait son état comme on
accepterait notre situation au moment
des les étrennes j'avais je m'en
rappelle mes cousines
j'en veux pas du tout à mes cousines
parce que elles sont pour rien mais ont
donné un billet à mes cousines à moi
vous donner une pièce pour faire voir la
différence
annuel annihilerait pas besoin et ça ce
sont des souvenirs qui marque surtout
dans une enfance pour ça que je suis je
peux l'avouer maintenant mais depuis six
ans que je suis ici je suis très heureux
avant je n'étais pas je t'aime et une
fois vous empêche de tout petit il
termine dame je connaissais pas et on
m'a on a présenté tous les enfants et on
est arrivé à moi et pour présenter on a
dit tiens je te présente la fille d'une
amie de l'us donc plus qu'à ma mère mais
ça je les touche j'ai jamais digéré
refusé oui on a je pense que pendant
longtemps même je sais pas encore
maintenant parce que on se voit pas
souvent mais on a toujours refusé que je
sois la fidh de l'uss mais vous savez
dans le les familles autrefois les ont
été un peu rigide sur ces questions là
semblait que cet enfant elle n'était pas
bien vu par tout le monde dans la
famille j'aurais dû à ce moment-là
imposer le père n'en jurerait quelqu'un
de ma famille je ne citerai pas m'a dit
un jour par j'étais petite fille que
j'avais cinq six ans que je n'étais pas
que j'étais une enfant naturel que je
voyais une assistance publique et moi
j'ai toujours cru
c'est pour ça que je me suis jamais posé
la question sur mon père son père a su
qu'elle était une enfant même si votre
père qui est parti oui il est parti
pourquoi mes parents n'étaient pas
mariés et lui il était marié
oui est ce que ça vous a manqué l'amour
d'un père je crois que non non je ne
suis jamais posé la question mais quand
j'ai appris que mon père était décédé
bah j'ai eu la peine ne pas l'avoir
connu simplement c'est tout les
décalages
j'avais 21 ans ce choix de menthe et un
an que j'ai appris que mon père était
mort le lendemain était un homme que
j'ai appris que ma mère était vraiment
ma mère
c'est oui
que tu fous là
[Musique]
non le temps d'asseoir encore sous la
boue tiers
il faut envoyer sadc un ancien patron
saint patron ben je sais pas où il est
parce que quoi
huawei très bien et puis on a tous à sa
demande et en font plus trop payé huit
mois d'octobre ta octobre - novembre
rien mais tape à 98,6 mais tous les
hommes et tout de suite j'étais aux
assedic nombre des lycées liqui moly
carole rien quand j'ai écrit quelques
lettres à 10 ans et 7 mois non ils
répondront par oui non je vais essayer
l'amérique par email à paris pour bush
ils peuvent pas déjà il ya là un yalla
yalla taille c'est n'importe comment
présenter quelque part première chose
qu'on est encore qu'ils ont ça me
regardait quand ils verront les règles
mais recevant le savoir c'est que je
faisais payer les gens leur lâche des
berbères en france
il faut que tu fasses une certaine
dimension comme les bleus tient comme
les immeubles
3nous les 2 020 parler
on le métro un tel mandat s'il ya du
monde sa présence l'associé du monde qui
peut plus sortir quand ils ne descendent
qui sert pas voir ses propos duquel tu
dans ta terre et s'ils voudront pas
monter tout le monde s'en va
oui parce que tommy j'étais pris dans la
foule mais maintiennent ont quand même
[Musique]
conte
les régimes des collabos 3 1%
nos deux ans
n'est ce pas
on
nous
[Musique]
franchement france en deux groupes
chose que je vois en première puis à
sonnette
richard a mis six mois pour trouver un
appartement à clichy et la première
chose qu'il a tenu à faire c'était de le
montrer rami avec fierté
ouais ou tout du moins un
ouais ouais
robin presse cloche qu'on n'ait pas une
famine bel et bien puisque je crois qu'à
dévier alors un peu s'il n'est pas assez
bien ce qui l'attend encore une fenêtre
ils ont toujours des corps aux affaires
ouais je choisis ah ah ah le clou que
j'ai aimé ici se faire une surprise à la
hache de la série face aux ja stationné
un truc
attention on va tomber
chanter
c'est chouette quand son taxi c'est
chouette
on ne devra pas dépasser
non mais pour les appeler à face à sedan
plein
j'avais moi aussi
déclarait mathématiques la faire
changer de tour est l atout séduction
j'aurais pu la merde j'aurais dans le
ciel de paris
c'est très beau puis en plus ça sera
notre viennent vous êtes tous les deux
des nains et vous vous retrouver
ensemble
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de nous
parquer des films d'ivoire dans un
ghetto non comme un ghetto on sait on
s'est mêlé à la foule
ici les gens c'est des personnes
normales eh oui si nous sommes séparés
tout ici c'est chez lui le fait de vous
marier avec un homme mais comme vous est
ce que ce n'est pas vous renfermez non
quand j'ai aimé richard s'est pas j'ai
pas vu lui physiquement j'ai l'homme en
particulier
je n'ai pas vu qu'il était neil ont pu
être n'ont pu être géant a laissé
richmond humaine que j'ai que j'ai aimé
dès que je dis moi ça fait tilt ça fait
il ya eu une étincelle de moi j'ai mon
âge et j'étais flatté coup de foudre
pour vous et vous allez avoir des
enfants at on aimerait avoir des enfants
espérons qu'on si on peut nous voulions
voir je pense que moi j'adore les
enfants
je parle
richard adore les enfants et on conçoit
pas notre vie sans enfant et si on peut
en avoir mon nom n'est pas sur le banc
tout ça dépendra de pas mal de choses
ça dépend de quoi s'il elle qu'on
pourrait se dire si on nous en donne
l'autorisation
qu'est ce qui donne l'autorisation
les médecins et quels sont les risques
ya 80% de chances temps dont le peugeot
semble un peu parce que son champion
sans dispose pas comme nous on est quand
et où les attendront plein de bureaux de
leur employeur
il peut être aussi de taille normale
aussi je pense qu'il ya sur tous les
deux cas c'est qui peut être accro et de
taper de taille non on de taille normale
oui bon boulot la troisième hypothèse de
ca de 10 ont doublement à condroz c'est
à dire l'odeur non viable à ce moment là
j'ai ya des risques aussi pour moi il
risque pour l'enfant
et puis d'avoir sur toi ça je pense
qu'il faut d'abord on réfléchit depuis
que je connais avant je tenais je peux
pas dire que je n'ai pas à la vie mais
enfin à vie pour moi on présentait rien
puisque rénale représente bout
[Musique]
je l'attendais plus longtemps cette
aventure c'était toute ma vie j'ai voulu
je voulais fonder un foyer et puis
maintenant mon nom je suis prête à
l'affronter avec lui
[Musique]
haletant le tout après midi on est parti
faire des courses avec un peu de soleil
il pleut pas à gaza c'est déjà ça alors
à petit prend des claques potati francs
je vais faire une boîte
oui
anti-fraude éclate toi tu l'as dit fera
c'est pas l'affluence
ouais
trop tard
là
[Musique]
annie n'était jamais allé dans un grand
magasin dans celui où richard l'a emmené
pour déposer leur liste de mariage
nous avons été frappés par la curiosité
parfois l'ironie que leur passage
provoquèrent
[Musique]
les anciens je pense que ça va nous
manquer
rés
attention la soul blues tableau
c'est affreux voici celle là n'a
toutefois un lait alors là c'est celle
du crayonné les 86 attend ce soir là
c'était l'anniversaire de richard moi
bonjour c'est toi mon dieu qu'est la
fête à léo ville pas du nom c'est elle
qui boit c'est pas toi
bongo qui a mené mer - défendez mais je
crois plus au nord il ne m'étonnerait
pas que du sang italien dans les mêmes
types qui commence comme ça disait ça
durera pas longtemps
tous n'ont toujours pas une question ça
va tu sais que dans ce mois en espagne
et correspond ça s'arrose
qu'est ce que tu penses de deux ans
marie tous les coins et nous tombons pas
dans mon coin de moi je voudrais bien
vous allez vache pendue croate
pourquoi pourquoi tu penses à opérer
comme on aurait dit qu'est ce que je
peux à ce cas pourquoi ne pourra que
quand on est un dans la rue tout quand
on les deux n'ont en fait pas
franchement ton avis
parce que vous vous êtes tout est de la
même taille un risque de non mais là non
avec pat enjeux sont a fait plusieurs
fois l'espère l'extérieur on a discuté
quand on est tous à l'on passe mais
quand on se balade et les quattro ebace
pas étonnant alors observé
le genci j'ai déjà des décanter 2 c'est
normal non ce dimanche je suis tout seul
oui héberger tous les gens face aux
voyageurs
et quand la moitié du wagon kevlar
braqués sur moi oui et compte élargir
que je regarde je me suis pas mis une
chose ils étaient entre eux sauf eliane
une personne dite de taille normale les
cous de roland 1-1 arméniens américains
au quotidien auprès d'alice je fais la
bise à bille complet la preuve il est
alors est ce qu'il va faire mais richard
[Musique]
à la nôtre alala la rupture il ya vous
avez épousé rammelaere je peux pas dire
que la vie soit facile la vie est très
dure
j'ai perdu ma famille j'ai perdu phase
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais la vie est très très dur et je sais
je me ressens aussi si vous voulez ça me
pose des problèmes pour nous mais pour
mon travail c'est quand on voit mon mari
on joue pas mme denis de travail mais
quand vous allez vous présenter vous
venez pas maintenant je vais pas avec
mon mari mais quand ils n'apprennent ils
finissent bien par là prendre un jour
bon bah là j'ai des licenciés pour ça
que je choisisse mes amis et beaucoup de
gens qui ne comprennent pas ou qui nous
traite de folle même de peu mal elle est
plus loin de de sadiques et vicieuse et
quand vous entendez ça commence que vous
réagissez je me pose des questions sur
vous pouvez penser qu'ils ont raison non
ils m'ont poussé à divorcer il ya déjà
14 ans vous remarquez qu'on pousse est
divorcé depuis notre mariage
mais disons que le chômage n'arrange
rien au contraire alors qu'est-ce qu'il
vous dise c'est sûr va je me dise que
mon mari est un bon à rien que même pas
capable de nourrir ta famille ton fils
et toi vous avez un enfant
oui un enfant de 9 ans qui est de taille
normale il sera pas très grande mais il
sera il fera un médecin quand
non bah oui d'accord oui il sera de
taille normale en masculin il est à
bourges dans la famille on y est
pourquoi parce que il est très heureux
là bas et qu'il n'a pas besoin de
compatir à ce qu'on pression afin de
participer à ce qu'on veut ce temps
c'est peut-être un peu lâche ce que je
vais vous dire mais bon bah si lui est
heureux du principal on pourra même
balle nourrir de toute façon donc il est
très bien où il est on n'avait pas de
vous et moi non je regrette pas d'être
mariée non si je les choisis c'est que
je savais au départ ce que je faisais je
n'ai accepté tous et tous les problèmes
que j'ai c'est à moi de les régler il
vous arrive de désespérer parfois oui
oui je me retiens mais sinon j'ai tout
ce qu'il faut sur moi au point de vue
médicaments oui et
michel elle aussi est dite de taille
normale et elle aussi elle a épousé un
homme serge serge par là c'est un
battant un bon vivant et à notre
connaissance c'est le seul d'un chef
d'entreprise encore at il hérité de la
sphère de son père même s'il a su la
développer aujourd'hui il dirige 15
employés
c'est un vrai couple qui a pris le
risque d'avoir un enfant
il y avait 50% de chances pour que cet
enfant soit de taille normale le sort en
a décidé autrement
et eux qui voulaient beaucoup d'enfants
ont dû y renoncer
aujourd'hui il regrette de ne pas avoir
pris un second risque
je ne peux pas mais qu'on soit en dehors
de la société en dehors des gens normaux
il faut je me défendre tous les jours et
pour prouver
j'étais normal qu'une personne normale
mais je souffre je sens tout les jours
que je ne suis pas une personne normale
mais heureusement que j'ai beaucoup
d'amis aussi bien de mon métier mon
métier j'ai des collègues qui sont
formidables qui m'a prévenue alors je me
sens qu'ils me prennent pour un anormal
allez que j'arrive à ça oui elles mêmes
en retard que vous voyez comment est ce
que vous avez dit
je lui ai jamais
c'est un aperçu bien fait à plusieurs
reprises analyse et enfin petit verre
encore jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans jallet va
chercher à l'école puisque on allait
quand même un petit lot médecins sage
allait la chercher à l'école est intacte
il faisait bon on remontait à pied et où
c'est ont marché à l'avenir les ombres
et alors cela et me disais oh là là mon
masque je serai grains de communes toi
et puis je ne savais pas trop comment
lui dire que je disais peut-être pas
marie-hélène simple pas tout à fait
comme moi tu seras peut-être je me
rappelle me disais toujours là non je ne
veux pas être comme papa je voudrais
comme toi tu as l'air de vous faire de
la peine les violations oui oui bien sûr
parce que je sais que c'est de ma faute
je suis c'est de ma faute que les comme
moi on n'était pas fier d'être comme
papa donc tellement il ya des moments je
je je pense qu'elle m'en veut plutôt à
moi qu'à son papa il me semble je me
plonge de 26 ans 11 ans vous l'avez dit
non pourquoi
j'allais par du sable je voyais qu'elle
m'en voulais bon là j'ai remarqué ça
l'était était très complexée déjà
comment vous qu'elle était complexe et
qu'elle vous en voulez commencent à se
manifester
ben ne sortait pas beaucoup reste à la
maison et puis elle ne parlait ne parle
pas beaucoup
elle parlait pas je ne voulais pas
sortir ne voulais pas le côtoyer les
autres personnes ne voulaient pas
fréquenter des amis voulaient pas de
coppel et pas de copains alors je n'ai
pas compris le trait des rebelles était
à rennes ça devient honte de votre père
non pas spécialement
[Musique]
mais chez rona qu'est-ce que vous disais
je préférais par lettre jacques on prend
très à coeur
on la comprend même très bien tout ce
que je demande ce qu'elles trouvent un
emploi que puisse être mon associé et
qu'elle soit admise dans une société
qu'elle est comme ça elle n'aura pas de
problèmes c'est celle à l'emploi c'est
admis que la société n'aura pas ce
problème là
ray allen vous sentez pas admises dans
la société
aussi le nom
alors
[Musique]